this never thought for a second it was a
tumor on my face like never never never
I think when you think of a tumor I
think of like this big thing hanging
from that's what I do I just didn't know
but that image just gives me chills he
said it could have spread it any minute
Khloe Kardashian opens up about a
personal health scare revealing just how
serious it really was try to find the
positive in everything so that's what
I'm trying to take from this Khloe opens
up on the latest episode of Hulu's the
Kardashians about learning she had skin
cancer on her face and cameras were
rolling documenting the emotional
waiting game after the doctors did a
biopsy to learn more I had to have the
surgery where they removed the tumor
from my face and they had to sort of
open up my cheek I guess when they were
reviewing the labs a lot more than what
they thought had to be removed this was
way more serious than I
either understood or I anticipated it to
be and so what they just don't know is
if it's pre-cancerous or if it already
went to cancer and melanoma is deadly
and it's a lot like the stitches was
like crazy back in October Club
explained why she was wearing bandages
on her cheek telling fans about her
cancer scare and urging them to get
checked and frequently I'm definitely
anxious about everything and now you
just have to wait I think this is when
when you're waiting on results is sort
of when your mind can just like go to
different places you start thinking okay
well what if I do have can't like what
if the cancer did spread and then you're
like you just start thinking these crazy
things I just had another baby and you
just spiral Into Darkness
of course all this came shortly after
the good American founder welcomed her
second child a son named Tatum with her
ex Tristan Thompson the two also share a
five-year-old daughter true my favorite
part about being a mom I mean it's so
corny but it's just like no matter how
tired you are whatever you just it's
complete Bliss I think also motherhood
just puts life into perspective and
what's important to you Chloe and the
NBA Pro split in December 2021 after
news broke that Tristan cheated on Chloe
and fathered a child with another woman
I was definitely very angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled the Revelation came just days
after Chloe claims Tristan encouraged
her to do an embryo transfer to have a
second child together via surrogate it's
just so close I wouldn't want anyone to
think I did this after the fact
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else I don't think I've seen
you this low thankfully Chloe got a bit
of good news from the doctors they
removed the entire tumor and all her
margins were clear I feel really
fortunate and really blessed I feel like
I've gone through a lot recently
but bring it on from now anything
negative Return to Sender
well you guys you're not welcomed here
don't want it don't need it I'm done